okay he's the first one Hey 2.7 colors
and it was to show what that's equal to
in meters okay now a very small number
of you actually went and drew the
diagram that will help you with this
right now do you have to do the diagram
know the marks there's a diagram itself
give you a marks not but if you did the
diagram you almost certainly got some
exactly coming okay so let's just very
very briefly draw it
it's the metric one right so there are
four units on it from biggest to
smallest
it goes kilometers meters centimeters
and millimeters okay you draw the whole
theme journey the whole thing's actually
much easier than just join parts of it
because there's a pattern to it okay so
here's the way it works from Colonus to
meters right for example two kilometers
is literally like the kilo means
thousand right so it's two thousand
meters you have to multiply it by a
thousand when you go down the next time
you multiply it by 100 cuz meetup
centimeter century since you know
anybody and down here you multiply by
ten yeah now millennium means from beta
to millimeters there's a thousand right
so that's why there's a hundred here ten
feet you're multiply them together you
get that
now if you wrote this out okay I'm in
virtually guarantee you got the right
answer so here's what I would do I'd say
kilometers meters so I'm k2 here yeah
okay so I even write down 2.7 times a
thousand that's what I actually have to
do you calculate up if you're struggling
with doing your place values correctly
it will tell you the rest
it's 2,700 okay sir that's the way that
I actually will write this down I have
this whole framework in my head on the
paper and then identify the part that's
most useful to me now the next one is
tricky for two reasons number one it's
going in the other direction okay
because you go from centimeters which is
a little unit right to kilometers which
is a big unit
so if we're going to go in the other
direction then instead of multiplying
this way what do we do we define that's
exactly right
so instead of multiplying by 10 we
divide by 10 here divided by a hundred
here and divide by a thousand here right
now the second challenge of this problem
is that you're not just going one step
right see how he would just make
kilometers to meters and that was fun
okay but here we going from some
centimeters to meters then to kilometers
okay sorry I'm going to divide by take
his 5,800 and what do I divide by you
think about a couple different ways you
can either say let's go from centimeters
to meters first let's just do one step
right so you divide by a hundred okay
and that'll give you the number of
meters but then you're going to go
another step you're going to divide by a
thousand after that and that'll give you
kilometers okay now you can either write
that or alternatively you can do you can
do both nodes two views at the same time
instead of doing a hundred and then a
thousand you just do a hundred thousand
okay that'll be then we'll do both at
the same time okay now that should give
you the right number when she is point
all right yeah there you go okay so
really the important thing is not this
you point fees these two right that's
how you actually get the right answer no
you can be confident okay so now the
last one I reckon you can talk me
through this we've got twenty thousand
millimeters we want to invade this if
you got this wrong you should write down
which is about fifty percent you some of
you find them
now which way are we going are we going
for big units - small units of small
units to be units which smaller be
because millimeters are tiny and meat is
much bigger right
how many steps are we going two steps
from here to here and then from here to
here okay so let's try doing both at the
same time yeah 20,000 what do I divide
by a thousand that's exactly right
because divided by a hundred and
dividing by ten together
it's dividing by a thousand so that's
why the answer is just 20 meters